versteckte tunnel die amerikas größter
stadt das überleben sichern
[Musik]
das war damals das teuerste bauvorhaben
in den usa
[Musik]
ein schiffswrack mit bewegter
vergangenheit und einer
ausserordentlichen fracht dieser
meeresregion birgt tödliche gefahren für
schiffe
eine betonpumpe die hitlers wunderwaffe
verbergen und schützen sollte
[Applaus]
wir dran waren den krieg zu verlieren
seit dieser bau
und ein gespenstisches relikt aus der
zeit des kalten krieges
riesige klaffende löcher in der decke es
sieht aus als sei er etwas furchtbares
passiert
[Applaus]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind rote lebensgefährlich
verseucht doch wer waren ihre erbauer
wie wurden sie errichtet und warum
wurden sie wieder aufgegeben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mitten in der französischen provinz
steht eine seltsame beton struktur
[Musik]
ein außergewöhnlicher anblick
eine riesige betonkübel umgeben von
grünem ackerland
dieser ort ist totale science fiction
ganz im ernst es gibt nichts
vergleichbares
allein dass hier die form dieser öffnung
man da etwas reingeschoben
wirklich seltsames gebäude
von außen sieht man dass es hier eine
art eingang gibt es sieht aus wie in
einem james bond film wie das versteck
eines schurken
in ihnen für ihren grundlegenden 40
geschlagene höhlen in die tiefe
kilometerlange tunnel in alle richtungen
verlieren sich im dunkeln
[Musik]
die gesamte anlage war mit stahlträgern
abgestützt was darauf hindeutet dass
hier etwas sehr wertvolles untergebracht
war aber was
niemand sonst hat er vergleichbares die
bahn ihrer zeit um 20 jahre voraus
doch was für eine anlage ist dass wer
hat sie gebaut und warum wurde sie zur
ruine
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt während des
zweiten weltkriegs der kriegsverlauf hat
sich zu gunsten der alliierten verändert
die wehrmacht muss verheerenden
niederlagen einstecken
als ich das blatt 1943 gegen die nazis
wendete holte hitler seine berühmten
wunderwaffen aus der kiste
eine spektakuläre erfindung musste hier
irgendetwas dass die alliierten auf die
bretter schickte am besten mit einem
einzigen vernichtenden schlag
doch die an erden luftangriff ersetzen
den deutschen fabriken schwer zu
[Musik]
also beschließt hitler wichtige
produktionsanlagen unter die erde zu
verlegen und unterirdische fabriken zu
bauen
eine davon befindet sich hier im
nordfranzösischen pas de calais
gebaut umsetzt heftigste angriffe zu
überstehen
diese anlage sollte zum stolz der nation
werden ein komplex der den krieg
entscheidet
[Musik]
im september 1943 beginnt der deutsche
baukonzern philipp holzmann mit dem bau
der bunker mehr als 1300 menschen
arbeiten tag und macht um diese
monumentale anlage zu errichten
man begann mit der kuppel um die
darunter liegenden stollen verbunden zu
schützen tief im inneren wurde am
vorbereitungsraum für die raketen
gearbeitet
besatzung stromversorgung und
frischluftzufuhr waren auch in den
stollen untergebracht
[Musik]
die anlage gleicht einer unterirdischen
kleinstadt einem futuristischen zentrum
für hitlers neue wunderwaffe
doch welche waffen sind das
[Musik]
solche geschosse hatte es bis dahin noch
nicht gegeben sie flogen schneller als
der schall kamen also geräuschlos und
explodierten in den ziel städten
das war eine völlig neue art der
kriegsführung
[Musik]
die bunkeranlage la coupole ist eine
abschuss station für die legendären v2
raketen in der auch bauvorhaben 21
genannten startbasis tüfteln hitlers
rüstungsexperten an ballistischen
raketen mit einer reichweite von über
300 kilometern
mit diesen vergeltungs wattenwyl hitler
rache für die bombardierung deutscher
städte nehmen
zu ihnen gehört die v2 einer der ersten
militärischen lenkflugkörper der welt
die v2 ist das erste von menschen
gemachte objekt das den weltraum
erreicht und hitler als letzte hoffnung
den krieg zu gewinnen
zuerst das hier ist ein luftschutzbunker
für bomben
55.000 tonnen beton viereinhalb meter
und hier direkt unter mir sollten die
raketen abgefeuert werden
[Musik]
die pläne der anlage waren streng geheim
doch klar ist hier sollen die raketen
betankt zu einer startrampe gefahren und
abgefeuert werden
[Musik]
die vol 2 sollte angst und schrecken
verbreiten wo auch immer sie einschlägt
sie fliegt bis an den rand des weltalls
stürzt von dort mit
überschallgeschwindigkeit ohne jede
vorwarnung auf die erde und löst eine
infernalische explosion aus
doch warum wird die anlage ausgerechnet
hier im norden frankreichs gebaut
alkohol ist nur 45 kilometer vom
ärmelkanal entfernt und damit in
optimaler schlagdistanz zum hauptziel
london
[Musik]
hitler wollte täglich dutzende v2
raketen von la coupole aus nach london
feiern das heißt die anlage musste in
der lage seien hunderte raketen zu
lagern und rund um die uhr zu
produzieren
die einzelnen raketen komponenten sollen
in einem labyrinth von unterirdischen
gängen lagern und im vorbereitungsraum
montiert werden
die fertigungsanlagen waren vertikal
angeordnet das heißt die spezialisten
haben der v2 auf jeder ebene einzelne
komponenten hinzugefügt
trotz äußerster geheimhaltung bleibt der
bau von la coupole den alliierten nicht
verborgen
im märz 1944 fallen die ersten bomben
auf die betankung
[Musik]
noch bevor eine einzige v2 aus lake
powell abgefeuert wird setzen die
alliierten ihrerseits neue wunderwaffe
nein eine davon ist eine bunkerbrechende
fliegerbombe namens toll
sie wiegt 6 tonnen und ist mit torpedos
sprengstoff gefüllt
photoline schlägt bleibt kein stein auf
dem anderen
bis juli 1944 gab es insgesamt etwa 20
angriffe auf die anlage dabei warfen die
briten 3000 tonnen sprengstoff ab
darunter bei zwei einsätzen auf 32 toll
wie
eine bombe schlägt direkt neben der
kuppel ein und verschüttet die eingänge
zu zwei tummeln
die bauarbeiten müssen eingestellt
werden ende juli 1944 wird la coupole
aufgegeben
heute ist die anlage eine ruine
[Musik]
wie nah wir dran waren den krieg zu
verlieren seit dieser baum
nur ein jahr später hätten die deutschen
von hier aus täglich 50 raketen auf
großbritannien abgefeuert zum glück
hatten sie diese zeit nicht mehr
[Musik]
45 kilometer südwestlich von berlin
steht ein herrschaftlicher
gebäudekomplex
[Musik]
nur wenige orte in europa scheinen noch
immer unter einer dicken staubschicht zu
schlummern
an diesen orten kann man noch immer
unberührte geschichte finden
[Musik]
auf den ersten blick ist das anwesen gut
in schuss bis man genauer hinsieht
der putz bröckelt von den wänden
das ganze haus ist völlig verwahrlost
modifizierte tiere vertrocknen auf dem
teppich ihrer letzten ruhestätte
einhaucht leiser verzweiflung durch w
die herrschaftliche räume
[Musik]
überall verfall und trostlosigkeit
das theater hat schon lange keine
besucher mehr gesehen
[Musik]
unter schwimmbad kein wasser
in einem der räume befinden sich
wandmalereien mit kyrillischer schrift
[Musik]
vor dem gebäude steht trotzig eine
statue des komponisten führers linien
wer wollte sein andenken hier bewahren
[Musik]
in der nähe stehen kleinere gebäude die
noch verfallener sind
die fensterscheiben sind verschmiert aus
dem boden sprießen pflanzen in der decke
klaffen riesige löcher
alles wirkt als sei etwas furchtbares
passiert
man fragt sich welche macht diesem ort
vor gar nicht langer zeit ihren stempel
aufgedrückt hat
und dann spurlos verschwunden ist
wer hat in diesen häusern gelebt wie
sind sie genutzt worden und was haben
sie mit einer verdeckten
spionagemissionen der cia zu tun
um das zu verstehen muss man in die ära
des kalten kriegs zurückblicken als ost
und west sich unversöhnlich gegenüber
stehen nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg haben die
alliierten beschlossen das von
deutschland aus nie wieder eine
bedrohung für die welt ausgehen sollte
deswegen haben sie das land aufgeteilt
und besetzt
deutschlands schicksal entscheidet sich
endgültig im sommer 1945 auf der
potsdamer konferenz im schloss
cecilienhof
[Musik]
als die siegermächte sich hier treffen
liegt die kapitulation des dritten
reichs gerade einmal neun wochen zurück
winston churchill harry truman und josef
stalin halten ihre beschlüsse im
sogenannten potsdamer abkommen fest
es sieht vor dass westdeutschland von
den usa england und frankreich besetzt
wird während die sowjetunion die
kontrolle über ostdeutschland erhält
zugleich beginnen die russen damit ihre
neue westgrenze zu befestigen
schon bald eskalieren die politischen
und ideologischen spannungen zwischen
der sowjetunion und dem westen
ostdeutschland liegt direkt auf der
bruchlinie hinter dem eisernen vorhang
die sowjetunion will die staats- und
gesellschaftsmodell auf aus deutschland
übertragen und bauen ihre strategische
militärpräsenz massiv aus
erst muss um der nato eine starke
streitmacht entgegenzustellen und
zweitens um die parteilinie von moskau
bis hinein nach ostdeutschland zu
verlängern
[Musik]
350.000 rotarmisten sind in der
sowjetischen besatzungszone
stationiert es ist das größte
truppenkontingent über so lange zeit auf
fremdem boden
[Musik]
sie verfügten über modernste sowjetische
militär technologie
im fall eines konflikts wären diese
hochgerüsteten truppen der nato
entgegengetreten
[Musik]
das oberkommando der sowjetischen
streitkräfte in deutschland bezieht
anfang der 1950 er jahre hier sein
hauptquartier
aber warum gerade in einem kleinen
abgelegenen ort in der brandenburgischen
provinz
jüngster vater in stadtteil von zossen
ist schon seit dem ausgehenden
neunzehnten jahrhundert eng mit dem
militär verbunden
1933 verlegen die nazis ihre
panzertruppen nach wünsdorf
1938 folgt ihnen das oberkommando der
wehrmacht nach der kapitulation kommt
die rote armee jürgen naumann kennt die
ganze geschichte
die militärobjekte der damaligen
wehrmacht die waren eben noch top in
ordnung also man brauchte nicht neu
bauen man musste nur beziehenden paar
umbauten machen so schätze ich dass ein
dass gerade hier nähe von potsdam nähe
von berlin eben das oberkommando
stationiert wurde
de geheimakten belegen dass ostdeutsche
offiziere hier auf linie gebracht werden
und hochrangige sowjet offiziere
diskutieren die wahrscheinlichkeit eines
krieges mit dem westen
doch die sowjets müssen sich auch um
andere probleme in ihrer besatzungszone
kümmern
aus berlin gab es einen streich von
bauarbeitern der sich schließlich zu
einem volksaufstand hochschaukelt
das konnten die sowjets nicht tolerieren
und schickten ihre panzer los
menschen mit steinen können gegen panzer
nicht viel ausrichten der ostdeutsche
widerstand wird schnell niedergeschlagen
seitdem ist jedem klar dass dies ein
totalitärer staat ist
die rote armee war in deutschland um die
deutschen zu kontrollieren und um dem
westen die stirn zu bieten
als diese deutschen dann aus der reihe
tanzten hat die rote armee kurzen
prozess mit ihnen gemacht
[Musik]
doch warum hat ein militärhauptquartier
so viele freizeiteinrichtungen
hier lebten ja nicht nur die
streitkräfte sondern auch ihre familien
[Musik]
im hauptgebäude
da war sozusagen ausstellungen
gedenkt räume
dann waren kleine kino räume da wo immer
propaganda film
gezeigt worden
[Musik]
die in deutschland stationierten
offiziere der roten armee genossen mit
ihren familien einen hohen
lebensstandard ähnlich aber besser als
zu hause in der sowjetunion
in der ddr wird die russische garnison
klein moskau genannt
[Musik]
doch als die mauer am 9 november 1989
fällt ist die zeit der sowjets in
deutschland abgelaufen
[Musik]
die aufrechterhaltung der riesigen
sowjetischen infrastruktur in
ostdeutschland war enorm teuer
als das regime in der heimat kollabierte
endete bald darauf auch seine
militärpräsenz in deutschland
[Musik]
klein moskau wird dichtgemacht die
größte sowjetische garnison außerhalb
russlands ist geschichte
am 25 juni 1994 werden die rotarmisten
zum abschied mit einer finalen parade
geehrt
[Musik]
heute stehen teile der ehemaligen
garnisonsstadt wünsdorf zum verkauf doch
der geist der geschichte umweht die neo
barocken gebäude bis heute
[Musik]
jahrzehntelang war deutschland im
brennpunkt der geschichte die spuren
dieser zeit sind bis heute vielerorts
sichtbar
es sind die spuren der großen
besatzungsmächte die hier viele jahre
lang unglaublich viel investiert haben
[Musik]
30 kilometer format in dem nördlichsten
punkt irlands liegt ein seltsames objekt
auf dem meeresgrund
[Musik]
60 meter unter der oberfläche des
dunkelgrauen atlantiks bereitet sich ein
unübersichtliches gewirr von algen
bewachsenem metallschrott aus
in dem tiefen trüben wasser werden die
umrisse allmählich sichtbar und das
dämmert einem was hier los ist er sieht
man sieht einen propeller seinen rumpf
und eine menge rostiges metall
hier ist ein schiff gesunken
andere konturen passen nicht zu einem
boot
zu sehen aus wie kanonen schienen und
gefechts türme bei näherem hinsehen
zeigt sich dass es panzer sind aber
warum sind die nicht an land sondern auf
dem meeresboden
seltsamerweise sind es amerikanische
schirmen panzer die hier vor irland
liegen
[Musik]
tatsächlich ist das ein großer
schiffsfriedhof
erliegen ozeandampfer und u boote
diese meeresregion birgt tödliche
gefahren für schiffe
was geschah mit diesem schiff warum hat
es us panzer transportiert und liegt
jetzt auf dem meeresgrund
[Musik]
eines der verlustreichsten gefechte des
zweiten weltkriegs liefert die antworten
die atlantic schlacht
als insel war großbritannien im zweiten
weltkrieg abhängig von alliierten
nachschublieferungen
die haupt transportroute führte von den
usa und kanada über den atlantik ihr
funktionieren war für das land eine art
lebensversicherung
die atlantic passage war elementar um
sich nachschub zu besorgen und sich
verteidigen zu können
hitler wusste dass er england einen
schweren schlag versetzen würde wenn er
diese wichtige versorgungsroute gehabt
es ist hitlers ziehen so viele
handelsschiffe wie möglich auf den
meeresgrund zu schicken er hofft
großbritannien so aushungern isolieren
und schließlich zum aufgeben bewegen zu
können
doch welche rolle spielt das panzer
beladen der frack vor marin hat dabei
die empire heritage die hier auf dem
meeresgrund liegt ist ursprünglich ein
walfangschiff
1941 wird sie von einer mine beschädigt
und außer dienst genommen doch sie
bekommt eine zweite chance
[Musik]
sie war nicht gerade das juwel der
handelsflotte aber damals wurde jedes
boot gebraucht also wurde sie zusammen
geflickt und zwischen liverpooler new
york eingesetzt
[Musik]
dabei passierte sie jedesmal malin head
für die schiffe war dieser teil der
reise einer der gefährlichsten wieder
taucher jeff miller zu berichten weiß
[Musik]
kann ein sehr heimtückisches gewässer
seien es gibt hier starke strömungen und
man ist der geballten kraft des
atlantiks ausgesetzt der nächste halt
noch mal in het ist amerika tausende
kilometer weit entfernt hier spürt man
die pure energie des meeres nur wählen
wasser und stürme
die mp heritage gehörte zu einem fast
100 schiffe großen konvoi der new york
im august 1944 verließ
sie war auf dem weg nach liverpool und
hatte große mengen kriegs güter an bord
unter anderem 16.000 tonnen öl und fast
2000 tonnen fracht
darunter auch
als schutz gegen deutsche u boote hatte
die royal navy ein neues system
eingeführt es sah vor dass 30 bis 70
handels frachter von schiffen der royal
navy eskortiert werden sollten
drei monate nach die idee sind die
alliierten auf der siegerstraße zwar
sind die kämpfe nach der landung in der
normandie verlustreich im laufe der
operation overlord fallen
schätzungsweise
65.000 alliierte soldaten
weitere 18.000 gelten als verschollen
und
155.000 man sind verwundet
doch nach drei monaten erbitterte kämpfe
ist der widerstand der deutschen
schließlich gebrochen die alliierten
marschieren richtung deutschland um
jedoch nach berlin vorzustoßen brauchen
sie weiterhin große mengen an nachschub
zwar waren die lande köpfe in der
normandie gesichert aber der vorstoß von
frankreich nach deutschland erfordert
enorme anstrengungen und sehr viel
ausrüstung
die alliierten bekommen ihr kriegsgerät
ihre truppen und ihren nachschub nicht
in die großen europäischen häfen
erst monate nach die del schaffen sie es
größere funktionstüchtige häfen unter
ihre kontrolle zu bringen
[Musik]
bis ende 1944 laufen fast alle
logistischen operationen über
großbritannien
schließlich erreicht die empire heritage
die irische küste
sie ist auf der zielgeraden nach
liverpool
war zwar nicht selbstgefällig aber die
atlantic schlacht war gefühlt vorbei
tatsächlich hatte sich die situation
seit 1943 beruhigt nach dem
erfolgreichen die der überquerte man den
atlantik freier
als die empire heritage 30 kilometer
formalen head ist kommt es zur
katastrophe
[Musik]
das deutsche u-boot
482 das unter der wasseroberfläche
lauert nimmt den frachter ins visier
es ist gefürchtet wegen seiner
angriffskraft und tauchtiefe und gilt
als erfolgreichster urtyp der see
kriegsgeschichte
er hat es nur das boot hatte einen
schnorchel und konnte dadurch viel
länger unter wasser bleiben es musste
kaum noch auftauchen und war deswegen
schwer zu entdecken
außerdem hatte es die jüngste generation
torpedos an bord die sich nach dem
geräusch eines schiffs propellers
ausrichteten
zwei dieser topos treffen die empire
heritage
ein gepanzertes kriegsschiff würde nach
zwei treffern wohl nicht sinken aber
handelsschiffe sind nicht gepanzert sie
gehen unter in dem fall hat dieses
schiff einfach nur großes pech gehabt
die heritage hatte 16.000 tonnen benzin
geladen als der torpedo einschlug muss
das einen ungeheuren feuerball erzeugt
haben das ganze mehr stand in flammen
überall brennendes öl und feuer ein
furchtbarer tod
tausende seeleute verloren während des
zweiten weltkriegs auf frachtschiffen
ihr leben ein unglaublicher horror
als die empire heritage untergingen
starben mehr als 100 seeleute viele
waren noch sehr jung einige von ihnen
sogar noch teenager es war eine
menschliche tragödie
erst im jahr 1995 entdeckten taucher die
empire heritage auf dem meeresboden
[Musik]
sie ist ein unterwasser denkmal für den
heldenmut zehntausende handels seeleute
die den sieg im zweiten weltkrieg erst
ermöglicht haben
ohne sie hätten all die vielen schiffe
nicht nachschub männer und material nach
großbritannien bringen können sie haben
die soldaten auf die insel gebracht und
nur durch ihr opfer haben die alliierten
den krieg gewonnen
[Musik]
in westchester county
65 kilometer nördlich von new york city
gibt es erstaunliches zu sehen
[Musik]
man läuft auf einem pfad durch den wald
und plötzlich steht da dieser mysteriöse
stein turm
er ist rund und hat weder fenster noch
türen wer hat ihn gebaut warum steht er
hier welche funktion hat er
mehrere dieser graffiti bemerken stein
monolithen sind in der landschaft
verstreut als gehörten sie zu einem
untergegangenen reich
auch ein bunker artiges gebäude steht am
wegesrand das hier partout nicht ins
bild passen will
[Musik]
wenn man da rein geht stößt man auf
räder große hebel und dann eine art
sperre die per flaschenzug bedient wird
aber alles ist verrostet und offenbar
lange zeit nicht mehr in betrieb gewesen
hinter der eisen wand ist der eingang zu
einem dunklen tunnel in dem knöchel hoch
das wasser steht und der scheinbar
unfertig ist
[Musik]
die tunnel sind nicht rundherum durch
gemauert an manchen stellen nur bis zur
hälfte blickt man nach oben sieht man
den nackten fels so als sei der tunnel
nicht fertig gebaut worden
[Musik]
die röhre führt in einer sich scheinbar
endlos erstreckende dunkelheit
doch wohin führt sie am ende des tunnels
findet sich ein hinweis
wasser rauscht einen gestuften hang
hinunter über die schlucht spannt sich
eine imposante metallbrücke
aber wie hängt das alles zusammen
anfang des neunzehnten jahrhunderts ist
new york bereits die größte stadt der
vereinigten staaten mehr als
250.000 menschen leben 1830 in der stadt
die infrastruktur kann mit dem
bevölkerungswachstum nicht schritt
halten
das problem in den schnell wachsenden
städten der neuen welt ist dass sie
meist nur umliegende wasserquellen
nutzen die bäche und flüsse in der nähe
doch wasser ist lebensnotwendig und wenn
man die wasserversorgung nicht
sicherstellen kann hat man ein
riesenproblem
verfügt seinerzeit nur über einige
brunnen und zisternen
abwässer siegern in das trinkwasser und
verursachen tödliche epidemien wie
gelbfieber typhus oder cholera
eine der größten cholera epidemien
bricht 1832 mit erschreckender
geschwindigkeit aus wer am morgen noch
gesund das haus verlässt kann am
gleichen abend bereits tot sein
insgesamt 3500 15 new yorker
größtenteils aus den armen vierteln
sterben an der neuen fest wie die
infektionskrankheit genannt wird
selbst die bewohner der noble führte
reicher städte wie london oder new york
fürchteten diese epidemie sie breiteten
sich ungebremst aus und sorgten für
angst und schrecken
drei jahre nach dem ausbruch der cholera
wird new york abermals heimgesucht ein
großbrand zerstört fast 700 gebäude im
stadtzentrum
die häuser waren aus holz und standen
dicht an dicht geriet ein haus in brand
konnte in minuten die halbe stadt in
flammen aufgehen
new york braucht wasser und zwar viel
davon die frage ist nur woher soll man
es nehmen und wie bekommt man es in die
stadt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die stadtverwaltung beschloss nach dem
vorbild der alten römer ein aquädukt zu
bauen es sollte eine nie dagewesene
ingenieursleistung
[Musik]
der plan sah vor den truppen rehwald
nördlich von new york aufzustauen und
sein wasser über einen 66 kilometer
langen kanal in die stadt zu leiten
das crotta produkt war ein riesenprojekt
das wasser bis runter nach manhattan zu
bekommen war damals wirklich eine
technologische herkulesaufgabe
doch wie soll das funktionieren
[Musik]
das aquädukt macht sich die schwerkraft
zu nutze um das wasser vom höher
gelegenen stausee bis in die stadt zu
leiten
die architekten mussten ein
gleichbleibendes gefälle über
unterschiedlichste gelände arten
hinbekommt
sie mussten thema überbrücken durch
hügel und felsen bohren
und die wasserleitungen mussten verdeckt
bis zum endpunkt immer ein konstantes
gefälle haben
das aquädukt wird in verschiedenen
abschnitten gebaut jeder einzelne davon
ist eine ganz eigene technische
meisterleistung so wie diese brücke hier
sollten die einzelnen abschnitte sich
später nicht nahtlos zusammen fügen
würde das wasser niemals in new york
ankommen
journalist jim mix hat sich mit der
geschichte des bauwerks beschäftigt
das aquädukt ist tatsächlich von hand
gebaut worden mit der muskelkraft von
mensch und tier alles musste per hand
ausgeschachtet werden von tieren
abtransportiert und schließlich ohne die
hilfe moderner maschinen fertig gestellt
werden
an einigen stellen musste man tunnel
durch die berge treiben durch hartes
gestein sowie in diesem bereich hier
also schaffte man hand bohrgeräte her um
durch den fels zu kommen hier sieht man
noch die spuren der alten burg köpfe
die bohrlöcher wurden dann mit
schwarzpulver gefüllt und der fels
gesprengt
das war eine unglaublich schwierige und
gefährliche arbeit jederzeit roten
felsstürze das schwarzpulver war
hochexplosiv so viel konnte schief gehen
die ingenieure fürchten dass sich
giftige gase im aquädukt bilden könnten
die das wasser kontaminieren
deshalb bauen sie lüftungsschächte in
die tonne 1
21 von ihnen stehen heute noch
sie haben verschiedene funktionen vor
allem sorgen sie dafür dass die luft in
den tunneln zirkulieren kann so dass
sich kein druck aufbaut
sie führen dadurch aber auch dem wasser
luft zu so dass es frisch bleibt
und schließlich diente jeder dritte oder
vierte lüftungsschacht auch als zugang
in das tunnelsystem
doch viele rückschläge verzögern das
projekt anfang 1841 bricht ein teil der
talsperre ein und flutet die umgebung
drei menschen sterben dann treten die
überwiegend irischen arbeiter in den
streik um gegen der hals kürzungen zu
protestieren
man darf nicht vergessen dass damals
alles von hand gemacht werden musste
eine ganze armee von arbeitern
größtenteils ihre stämmig hat über jahre
hinweg brutal hart gearbeitet um das
mammutprojekt zu ende zu bringen
[Musik]
als ein tal überbrückt werden muss
schaffen die männer tausende tonnen erde
und fels in hand wagen heran um damit
eine damen böschung zu bauen
[Musik]
und in der talsohle graben sie einen
abzugs kanal wie die heimatkundler rinn
mevis kane erklärt
er wurde gebaut um das aquädukt vor ein
strömendem wasser aus den vielen bächen
und flüssen in der gegend von west
chester zu schützen
durch den abzugs kanal werden die
fundamente des aquädukt nicht beschädigt
wenn immer einfluss stark genug ist um
schaden anzurichten
baut man abzugs kanäle
nach fünf jahren bauzeit ist das mega
projekt schließlich fertig doch auch die
baukosten sind mit 13 millionen dollar
rekordverdächtig
das war damals das teuerste bauvorhaben
in den usa
am 22 juni 1842 ist das wunder werk
vollbracht eine 66 kilometer lange
wasserleitung die new york jeden tag mit
130 tausend kubikmetern frischwasser
versorgt
das aquädukt war von anfang an ein
riesenerfolg ohne es hätte die stadt
niemals in diesem tempo weiter wachsen
können
ich stehe jetzt hier im hauptkanal das
aquädukt wo das wasser floss an normalen
tagen wäre es mir bis zu den knien
gegangen oder bis zur hüfte
dahinter sieht man dieses große
metalltor mit dem man das wasser
absperren konnte um untere bereiche des
aquädukt zu entleeren
[Musik]
doch wenn es so ein erfolg war warum
wird das aquädukt heute nicht mehr
genutzt
anfang der 1800 80er jahre rund 40 jahre
nach ihrer fertigstellung konnte die
anlage new yorks steigenden wasserbedarf
nicht mehr decken
in gewisser weise fiel das aquädukt
seinem eigenen erfolg zum opfer sein bau
war so ein segen für new york dass die
bevölkerung der stadt dramatisch wuchs
und schon bald über stieg der bedarf die
leistung des alten quoten aquädukt
1885 entstehen das new product und die
talsperre sie liefern drei mal mehr
wasser als die alte anlage
um das alte bauwerk vor dem verfall zu
retten wird es 1974 als nationales
kulturdenkmal anerkannt
einige schmuckstücke wie die kamine oder
die belüftungsanlage sind noch da doch
je mehr die natur so überwuchert und je
seltener der mensch sie aufsucht desto
mehr verschwinden sie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einst waren sie symbole der macht und
des fortschritts heute sind sie
verlassen in diesen verfallenden bauten
allen die echos der geschichte nach sie
gewannen an krieg und terror aber auch
ein erfindergeist und menschliches
streben
[Musik]